good morning I'm Jim Levinson dean of
the Yale Jackson School of global
Affairs I'd like to welcome everybody
and of course a special welcome to the
president
arse's lecture is our annual Sunrise
Foundation lecture funded by the sunrise
Foundation the lecture features
prominent speakers who come to speak on
themes related to political and or
economic issues in Emerging Markets and
the sunrise Foundation also provides
fellowships to deserving graduate
students here at Yale from Emerging
Markets enrolled at the Jackson School
the title of President arse's talk is
emerging economies in Latin America
the Bolivian economic model
president arsene has been president
since November of 2020 he has served in
the Bolivian public service for the
entirety of his career beginning with
the Central Bank of Bolivia he has
served as minister of economic Affairs
and Public Finance under Evo Morales for
almost 14 years
as Minister he successfully managed the
Bolivian economy in a period of
unprecedented growth and poverty
reduction from 2006 to 2011 GDP grew by
an average of 4.6 percent per year
peaking at 6.8 percent in 2013 and quite
impressively at the same time
unemployment decreased inflation fell
and poverty was dramatically reduced a
pretty incredible record
he was elected president in October of
2020 with a majority of the votes
I will note with special pride and I
speak here for both Professor Caliendo
and myself uh president arse has also
taught economics and finance at various
universities
today's talk will be moderated by
Professor Lorenzo Caliendo
Lorenzo is the wand Park Han professor
of global Affairs and also holds
professorship at the School of
Management
Lorenzo serves as Jackson's Deputy Dean
and is himself from Uruguay
so Lorenzo will start us off with some
uh talk some questions and and then
we'll open it up I also want to extend a
welcome to those who are joining us as
this has been live streamed uh to many
many around the world uh president arse
thank you so very very much for joining
us here at Yale
Lorenzo
[Applause]
that's uh after acting that introduction
I think it's uh president why don't you
actually give your your talk you were
thinking about actually talking in the
in the podium or you want to do it
sitting from here I think there's so
that's great so why don't you first why
don't you start please thank you
foreign
good morning to everybody I'm very happy
to be here
Professor James Tobin University I will
always
have followed all the writings that he
has done and the old research that he
has so for me it's a pleasure to be here
in this University
um I would like to start
just
because I think the time is the worst
that we have in the world
so I would like to talk very briefly
about
what is the our model is
the principles the basics
and also it is very important for us the
results
in the both Fields economic and social
results which is very important because
at the moment we create this model
in 2005
with Professor Carlos Villegas who was
working with me at the University
at the time
we will have to fail we have to fail
with the neoliberalist model who watch
who was in place in Bolivia for 20 years
since 1985 to 2005
20 years of neoliberalism in Bolivia and
there were no model no there is there
were no alternative models to face or to
replace the neoliberalism one so
when we started to do that it took a
many years to develop this we have to
face many many problems and you will see
a
a graph which we will compare you know
what we
the the
neoliberalist model against the our
model were the most important
differences and results of each one
so I will start very briefly talking
about the basics of the our model which
we call economic social Community
productive model
and we have to put it those words
because it's a very long name for a
model
but it is important to say that at a
time we have to emphasize that the
economic
a policy should be and or is always
a social issue
economics
is mainly a social science
because we have to solve the problems of
people
and the neoliberalist model the market
models
don't take into account many times the
social issues
so we that's why we call it economic
social communitarian productive model
and also communitarian because we
recover from the indigenous people the
principles as solidarity another
principles and values that the
indigenous peoples have and you know
survive to the neoliberalism in my
country
unproducted because we are changing the
Bolivian the people's mind because we
would like to become a productive
country
rather than only trade or you know early
Services we would like to have a
productive countries which is another
way to do it so that is the the basics
of the what we
put that long name
and the basics
is that
a country should growth based on
the national resources a country has
getting economic accidents from them
and which is very important because it
is we are we are the antithesis of the
natural resource course theory do you
remember in your your lectures
and we demonstrate to everybody that a
country who
it has National resource can develop
based on the natural resources
which is very important for us that's
why at the beginning of our government
with President Evo Morales we
we put in place the nationalization of
hydrocarbons
and other another resources that now
under the new constitutions
is under control of the estate that's
the main issue there
secondly
we generate
economic surpluses
Excellence we call it
in order
that the state appropriates of the this
accident this Surplus
and why the estate has to be here and
that's the big issue at the time I think
still in many countries the debate that
if market economy or the estate in the
economy
we sorted this problem in 2006.
because we were
appointed that the state has to be in
the economy
it's a very important role of the
economy has to be related to the to the
state
and not to the market because the market
it's not
a equilibrium in the market when
normally there is no equilibrium in the
market
and normally in the market are two
players
offers and
the Wonders but one of them is always
winning
it's not a
an equilibrium in that market
so for us it's very important that the
estate has to be you know it has to
appropriate it
get
the
the surplus of the economy
in order to to do the third basic of the
model which is redistributed
the principal role of the state has to
be to redistribute it because we are
facing now and there are many books Mr
pikettis is doing a good job there
trying to understand the inequality in
the world
but who's going to resolve the
inequality the market no for our point
of view the market never will solve the
problem
who is going to be the the the
solver of the problem is of course
this state
so
generate surpluses accidents
the state appropriated and redistributed
why we would like to redistribute income
surpluses in the economy
because we were to resolve the
inequality and the poverty that we are
facing in 2005.
so that's the principles very easy when
when
you look at the models and Professor
Tobin shows us in a very good manners in
many researchers that the models have to
be very simple
in order to succeed
and the principles of our model as you
can see it's very easy
to generate accidents from the natural
resources in my country redistributed
among people by the Estates to resolve
the problem of poverty and inequalities
that's it
that's the model in a very easy way a
very uh
short way
that's the way our model works
on the left hand side we have the
national resources we have hydrocarbons
mining electricity all the Strategic
sectors
we get the the money from those sectors
in order to redistribute them the state
is in the middle of it receives the
money on the surpluses and do the
redistribution process not only
generating a new country
industrialization and industrialized
country
with the industry manufacturing and so
on generate income employment and so on
but also as you you can see it in the
bottom of the of the graph you see the
ink of the distribution and poverty
reduction process
which comes from
the income the the resources that we can
derive in the surpluses from the
national resources that's it it's very
very simple the principles that our
model has
and in in this
in this one you have the some of the
differences with the neoliberalist model
which was in place in Bolivia since 1985
as you can see it up to 2005.
and in the right hand side of the graph
you see the economic social commentary
productive model which was to
two phases of it one from 2006 up to
November
2019 2019 which way we suffer a coup
d'etat
in Bolivia
the neoliberalist model came again
no wrongly from my point of view
and then when we restart our model in
November 2020 when I became the
president of my country we restarted and
of course we have a good result you will
see later on but those are the principal
differences you know the first one is
the most debated one
which is the free market against the
active presence and participation of the
estate in the economy that's the debate
you know
it's a long a long story in economics in
economics you know it's it's a long
story about that but in our case in a
less developing country
where we have a many indigenous people
poverty inequality
non-industrial industrialized country
and so on
for us is a solution that the estate can
resolve this problem and that's what we
have done so far
um one of the interesting things is that
the the neoliberalis model
are now every every time we are looking
at even even
every every year is less dependent but
um at the beginning what the
neoliberalist model used to say is that
in order to grow a country should export
you know we have a president in Bolivia
we used to say export or die
that was the
the beginning of the neoliberalism in my
country
and in my country we just die trying to
explore
so what we have done is to change the
engine of the model
is it to be the external demand should
be the internal demand
we should baste the growth
on people because people need to
get better life every day
become better days for everybody
and that is consumption that's
investment in a country node
working for other countries
so that's those are principles I would
say more important in order to
resume the main ideas of the model
now
we turn in some results that many of
them of course are in the IMF or Bank
report
and many International institutions
the first one is the growth rate you can
see in the in the average growth rate
from
1985 2005 it means the neoliberalist
model
the growth rate was three percent
the average
in our government in the first
government 2006 and 2019 2019
4.7 percent we increase
very clearly the growth rate and of
course here
2019 I know you know in 2020 about the
covid-19 and so on the the pandemic and
so affected of course all the countries
and italies we have a decreasing for 8.7
percent Great Road so you know we were
one of the countries in South America
that have you know the worst economic
performance at the time
when the neoliberalist model became
again in the the government
who gave the coup d'etat in Bolivia you
know
now we are increasing at four percent is
the growth rate estimated for this year
and uh I think we can do that better we
will see it what we are doing
another thing is that many times for six
times we we haven't put it in the in the
screen now but Bolivia was
in six times
the first growth economic rate in the
region
you some of them you you wait to 20 20
14 2018
but of course if you just look at a 2020
when neoliberal limbs came again to
Bolivia we were almost the last one in
Grove day but with a negative one you
know
so it means that our model
used to have better results than when we
are we were in the neoliberalness again
and this is very important we divided
the growth rate in Bolivia
for the source of the this growth rate
if you look at the blue
bluebird
it is the internal demand which it this
graph this graph shows you that the
internal demand is very important to
give us the growth rate
which it means internal demand means
consumption
means Investments in my country
who are the which are the which are the
the main issues that they that are
driven the growth in my country which is
you know very very
um
very clear with our model the
theoretical issue of the model the
internal demand is
driving the the growth rate not the
external demand which is the exports
minus Imports
which is the external demand which is
also negative for us and many many times
and in those years where we benefit from
the exports of course it works together
the external demand plus the internal
demand succeed in increasing the
evolution economy
this another one shows us a very
important thing for us because at that
time
um
everybody look at our government as a
socialist one and everybody you know
scared about the socialism
and they say socialists will take off
from you all your goods and so on and
there will not be no a
private Enterprises because the
Socialists what they want is to keep
everything for the estate and no private
Enterprises at all that's they used to
say
and this graph shows you that in our
government in under our model the
private sector increase much more than
they even did in the neoliberalism model
which of course shows you very clearly
that is absolutely absolutely compatible
with the private sector because it's
very easy to understand that when the
public sector invests you know it is
like like a train that every every old
all the all the cars afterwards are
pulled by the estate you know everybody
when the state invests you know there is
a multiplier impact in other sectors
private sectors and that's why you have
the impact you if you look at up to 20
and 5 only 7 74
000 public private Enterprises will were
in Bolivia
and now we have more than 355
000. private Enterprises working in my
country so it is very clear that we have
an impact also in the private sector
with our model
um the the per capita GDP which is very
important you know we started in 2005
with only 1 000 US dollars per capita
income
now we are three thousand forty thirty
seven US dollars so we multiply by three
be a
per capita GDP in our country which is
very important as you know
the inflation is not a problem in my
country
even now
accumulate inflation rate from January
to August is only
1.6 percent of inflation rate even in
these years you know when we in all and
know that the inflation is a worry for
everybody especially here in United
States in Europe very worried about
what's going on with the food prices
With the Energy prices and so on it has
to not worry in our country because we
have the lowest inflation in our region
and maybe would be in the the lowest one
of the countries which has had the lower
inflation in in the world I would say so
it is very important because we are
taking care about poor people our model
takes care of poor people
we look for them I mean we try to do
everything for protecting all the poor
people who lives in my country that's
why inflation is the worst thing for
poor people because rich people they
know how to protect them
but poor people they do have instruments
in order to protect from the inflation
rate so that's why we take care of the
inflation
the tray balance has improved in the in
this year from 2021 to 2022 we have
positive numbers in the past we were
looking at negative numbers in the trade
balance
but now we are improving because we have
a policy which substitute Imports input
substitution we call it the import
substitution process
we put in place in November 2020
and it's giving us good results we are
improving exports but also we are
reducing Imports showing that the
Bolivia has a big and enormous I would
say a production potential that we are
using now in order to reach these
figures as you can see in the graph
savings a number of deficits it's very
important look at at the flat
Savings in the financial system in the
neoliberalist model from you how you you
have in the graph here in the left hand
side left hand side graph in 1997 at up
to 20 20 25 2005 in The Early Brothers
model almost flat the uh the savings of
people and the saving started to
increase which our economic model
and we have from 5 000 million billion
US dollar we have now 31 a thousand year
so we have a lot of increase in the
saving people have more money that's
what they say
and also in the right hand side graph
you see
the increase of the loans
and the sorry the number of number of
accounts it's very important this this
number
we have started in 2005 with 1.9
thousand
uh
of accounts
in my country
and now we have more than 14 000.
of accounts it means that more people
now have more
deposits at the banks
which is very important in developing
countries because it means that not only
they have money now but the income they
have
you know is more than the spend
expenditures they have so they have a
margin of saving and those savings now
are increasing in the deposits and in
the number of accounts as well which is
very important and when we divide it
when we divide we would like to see if
the money that is the number of accounts
and the money that is getting in the
bank belongs to rich people of poor
people which look at you we divided the
the right hand side graphic the people
has that has less than 500 deposits
deposited in the in the banks
you know and so on at more than when 5
000 US Dollars deposited in the at the
banks and you will see that 87 percent
actually in the in Bolivia
of the account belonged to people who
have only a 500 US dollars or less
deposited in the bank at the banks so it
means that you know we have democratized
also the economy the money now they have
accounts and more people that have
accounts now in the at the banks is are
people that you know have less resources
less income that is very important
because it shows us yeah some of the
results of the redistribution model that
we put in place
the loans the financial system lost also
increase as you can see
and the non-performing loans are very
very low
comparing with with what happened in the
neoliberalis period you know
so if you look at
1997-28 even we have 16 percent of
non-performing loans
but now we have only two percent of
non-person Performing loans even in in a
period where we Face the pandemic and
everybody use the the the the savings at
the banks in my country and also they
they didn't have money and so they
didn't pay the debts the loans at the
banks because they didn't have money at
the time so even though even though we
have only 2.2 percent of you know
non-performing loans in uh in my country
also this is very important the
bolivianization process
at the
in the neoliberalis model
um
Professor Jeffrey sex who was the
advisor in the of that government at the
beginning of the neoliberalismol area
put in place
a dollarization process in order to fade
you know to face the um
the hyperinflation we suffered in 1982
to 1984 more where we look at an
inflation rate of 20 21
000 percent 21
000 percent of inflation of annual
inflation rate
so when
we became government in 2006 we started
to do many policies in order to
detolarize the economy and we succeed as
you can see in the graph
in the past in the neoliberalism model
only five percent of in the financial
system where deposits in in our domestic
currency which is El boliviano
but now we have 85 percent of people is
depositing money in domestic currency
and also in the loans
in the neoliberalis model seven percent
of the loans were made in domestic
currency
and now 99
of the loans are made in our currency
demonstrating the confidence of people
in our currency and their policy and in
all the results we were getting from our
model and now we don't have problems
with the dollarization in the economy
we are doing very well and people you
know trust in our domestic currency
which is for monetary policy you know
very important if people don't trust in
your currency you cannot do it any
monetary policies at all so it is very
useful for us to recover the monetary
policy from the generalization process
that the neoliberalism did in the past
of course Professor sucks now is not a a
neoliberalist professor you know has
changed his mind fortunately I would say
but at the time he advised this kind of
dollarization process
the global and current fiscal balance
get better if you look at
in the neoliberalist process we all
negative we have
more or less nine years of surpluses and
and then we started to have again a
fiscal deficit we were recovering from
that and then again
it came in my country and it started to
do bad the wrong economic policies we
again we have almost 13 percent of the
GDP as
fiscal deficit it's enormous one you
know and we've started to reduce it now
we are looking to have eight and seven
percent and so on all all these years we
were going to recover those figures in
this physical balance but you know you
you can see it easily what happened in
the fiscal sector
it is very important here
since we have put in place the
the
economic social communitarian productive
model in my country which is our model
uh we change the source of funding of
our public investment
in the past the public investment came
from mainly external resources that
external debt basically
now
the
two-thirds of the investment the public
investment in my country come from the
internal resources
you know and you can and you can
ask yourself what's going on why we
change the the the the source of the
funding of the investment the public
investment in my country and the reason
is that when you recover your national
resources you have money
you have money that money can't that in
the past were going out away you know we
keep the money in my country and started
to invest the money that came from the
national resources that's why very in a
huge change in the percentage of funding
now the source of the funding the of the
public investment
public investment by the way is one of
the key issues in our model
which is very Converse what we it comes
from the neoliberalized model where the
best of the neoliberalist model is of
course the private investment
in our modern the estate
is the main actor there so the public
investment is the main issue for us
that's why it changes do we we invest
more as a public sector and we have
results as you see and that's why
because we recover all the natural
resources and so on WE recover the phone
the source of funding our investments
the middle and long-term public debt is
not a problem in my country since our
model
but in the past as you can see you have
the the rate the ratio
external debt again GDP
you can see that in the past
[Music]
there were many years
that this ratio were more than 50
percent
but since our government since our model
we change it we reduce it because we
increase
the denominator of the equation
and reduce you know
the ratio and now we have only 28
percent of the ratio between a
external debt against GDP so we were
more comfortable now with the figures
macroeconomic figures as you can see
we increase the national minimum wage in
Bolivia we have a minimum wage for
everybody nobody has to earn a salary a
wage
less than that
and here I think we have in U.S dollars
yes
if you look at 2005 54 US Dollars it was
the minimum salary in my country and now
we have more than 30 20 323 US dollars
quick so in though in in this time we
have increased a lot the minimum wages
in my country so people is getting more
money
and if you look at the the the figure
the comparing the figure between our
country Bolivia into the 2005 we should
have we used to have
the lowest
minimum wage
in all South America
and now we are just in the middle
and you know if you if we continue with
this model I think we we were getting
better year by year
the unemployment rate also is a succeed
for us we used to have eight percent
almost nine percent of unemployment
in our government we in applying our
model we have more or less four percent
four point four percent 4.2 percent
and uh you know now we have 5.2
but but in 20
in 2020 we have 12 percent of uh of
unemployment rate you know under the
pandemic it was very very
worry about that but in any case
unemployment is also a variable that
shows you that we have improved a lot
and still there are some tool in this
variable but I think we succeed also in
reducing unemployment
also when we look at the social results
we have here how we reduce extreme
poverty and how we compare it with all
the South American countries did in the
same period
in the left hand side graph you will see
that we receive the country with 38
percent of extreme poverty in my country
and we reduce it up to 11
last year
even last year we reduced much more than
we did in the past so it means that the
model is working again it's working
again
and when we compare our results
with all the other countries in South
America that of course all the countries
are trying to reduce the poverty as well
you compare it Bolivia
reduce
more than everybody in in our region we
reduce in 20 percent 27 percent
uh Peru for example reduced it in almost
12 percent in the same period between
2005 and 2021.
so it means that our model not only
succeeds in getting good macroeconomic
results but also has good social
research which is an advantage of our
model that the neoliberalized model
cannot appropriate cannot talk about
because they never reach both
also the income inequality by Gina index
we reduce it we were a very inequality
country together with Brazil we were the
the worst in the in the region in 2005
we have 0.60
of genetic index
and now we are already 0.42
which is a huge reduction and again when
we compare our results
from those thou that the countries say
the in South America get you know it's
very I again Bolivia reduces in point 15
and all the other countries reduce it
less than we have done with our model
take it into account that many countries
Still Still they are using the
neoliberalist model
this is another very important things
the structure of the social stratum the
composition
of people according to the to the income
in 2005 60 of people in Bolivia were in
low income conditions
35 in Milling conditions and only four
percent in high income conditions
now when you compare we have 36 percent
in low income in conditions we reduce it
from 60 to 36
and we have increased the middle income
people from 35 to 60 percent
almost we double
the figure
from 2005.
so we have reduced poverty we have
increased the income especially in
delinquent and this not only our figures
I will show you some World Bank figures
later
also we reduce the differences between
the temperature the richest 10 percent
people in my country against the 10
percent richest people were a poorest
people in my country when you compare
the richest ten percent again the the
the poorest 10 percent we have a
difference of 128 times
in the past
but now we have only 20 times
still
some job to do yeah we are completely
agree but we have to use this a lot
especially in the rural area people who
live in the rural area they reduce more
the inequality among rich people people
and poor people
and as I promised here is the World Bank
this is a picture of the World Bank
they issue a report where it says the
income growth the poor is 40 percent
of the population who do the best in
order to reduce
that or some
improves
for the income
of the poorest 40 percent of a country
and you see here
Bolivia we have Market at the top
is the country
that increase the income of the police
40 percent
better than the other than any other
country in the world
uh in the world it is a world Bank
picture it's not our picture it's a
world Bank picture
we according to the world the the World
Bank we increase the income uh growth of
the police 40 percent in
12.5 percent
you know
Peru did let's say
nine nine percent nine and something
percent and so on so Bolivia
according to the World Bank is doing
better in improving the income growth of
the 40 percent of police people in my
country comparing with all over the
countries in the world so slows are
results and the last picture I have for
you
is this one that is very important
for us
which is the expectance
like the life expectancy at Birth
Bolivia if you look at the let's say the
blue bars
and we have a 64 years old of life
expectancy in 2005.
now we have increased it to 74 years
and you have all the countries there in
South America but in the
picture that is that is in the bottom
you will see
comparing
all the increases in life expectancy in
the region Bolivia has increased almost
11 years of life expectancy which is the
highest increase in life expectancy in
the region
for example Brazil increase in five
years old in the same period but Olivia
did in almost 11 years
so that's why
I haven't finished it with this figure
we say that our model
has succeeded not only in the economic
side
but also more important for us in the
social side because if we have a more
equal country
we have a better
country a better fitted country better
healthy country
we will have more and better results and
a better Society that's why that's the
objective when I say at the beginning of
the model reduce the poverty well we did
we have done and reduce inequalities
that also we have done we have reached
with this mother thank you very much
foreign
I think it was a very enlightening
conversation and hypothesis about the
Bolivian basically I would say new
paradigm in terms of think about growth
you know I have a i
have questions that are actually going
to start asking the president but I do
want this to be a conversation so in the
sense uh if people have questions please
raise your hand and I'm going to give
you the chance to basically ask a
question but uh let me start basically
first in uh so it's fascinating and uh
and clearly this is the data speaks by
itself right thinking about when when
they knew let's say economic model that
basically that you have proposed uh
because you were the Minister of Finance
during this period right so uh with EVO
Morales in in the macro if you see the
macro numbers are quite uh impressive
lower inequality lower unemployment
lower inflation and at the same time
more resources collected from the
government these resources coming from
as you were saying they're resource
based aspect of the economy so I guess I
have questions about
thinking about the long run thinking
about the long run so how do we how do
you think about first lessons what are
the micro lessons I'm going to be asking
that in a second but more thinking about
the long runs how do we a country that
like Bolivia that really depends on the
prices of Commodities or clearly you
were saying about importance of the
internal Market but these resources are
Global when you're thinking about
lithium when you're thinking about other
Commodities in the world they're driven
by global supply and demand so how do we
make this model sustainable in the long
run so I'll give you an example Chile
which has been an exporter of copper for
many years they have basically adopted a
fiscal rule a fiscal rule to basically
guarantee it somehow like a level of
spending that it's not fluctuating with
the commodity prices a another example
is Uruguay no surprise I'm from Uruguay
they're also just adapted a fiscal rule
we don't have a resource-based economy
as a case of Bolivia and there's other
resources that Uruguay basically
produces but we do get fluctuations and
commodity prices and that can explain a
big component of this macro imbalances
so I guess moving forward in uh and
apologize for the question it's more a
challenging question which is a good
question I would say sorry I would say
it's a very good question thank you
thank you very much for that so yeah
sorry so what do you think so let's how
do you how do we generate something
sustainable more in the long run let's
say rules not always work
uh in the you know and what happened
with rules and that those kind of uh you
know ways to mind the economy usually
break down very quickly because they are
not prepared for faced crisis like this
one for example and they broke the rules
and those bro those roads for example a
European Union it was three percent of
the fiscal deficit I don't know
how they will how they would work I mean
you know but anyway
um the better rule is the rule that is
flexible in my point of view
uh and in in order to answer your
question which is very good question the
long run you know
in the long run
we have to industrialize
our national resources we have to
increase the production of food the
agriculture sectors we have to improve
it in order to have no import dependence
at all
and that's we are working on
if you look at what happens in the in
this crisis for example fertilizings
you know and so on
uh went up and everybody cried and food
rise at prices and they were not full
all over the world everybody were
looking where to buy food
what we have to do is improve the
agriculture sectors to improve
productivity to to to become you know
less dependent at least if not totally
independent from the Imports of inputs
seats and so on because everybody is
looking for seeds for everybody and
that's the problem
that is the problem in my country we
have started to face this problem I mean
to to to do some policies in order to
avoid this probably in 2020.
when I became president of my country we
started to issue policies we started the
import substitution process policies we
put in place and so on that is the
difference we have these results rather
than all people that always you know
trusting on the globalization trusting
on Imports and free market and those
things that never worked because when
there is Crisis nobody is your friend
everybody's looking themselves
and that's why we are facing this
problem so
agriculture
if you don't have a
last smaller cars it doesn't incur but
if it does care if you don't have food
so that's the first thing that the word
has to do it you know
in our case the
countries which have a national resource
they have to industrialize it as soon as
possible
and of course in our point of view
according to the respecting the mother
earth
you know ecologic development which is
very important which is very important
is most costly
but we have to do it rich countries
didn't do it at the moment and at that
moment we have to do it so in our
countries it's much costly to become a
developed country but we have to do it
we have to develop all their natural
resources respecting I say again with
Mother Earth
and then you have to invest in education
you have to invest in health you have to
invest in many things and that is the
long run yes that is a law you if you
have food yes and you have education you
have invest in technology you have a
long-term uh growth rate
this is great this is great he's talking
about uh sources of growth and uh this
goes back to the textbook economics
model so human capital seems to be
important of course investment private
and public investment and I guess what
we're learning from from Olivia is more
like so we know the ingredients the
recipe it's a very local recipe the
Bolivian way of of doing this anyone has
a particular question we like to ask yes
please why don't you yes thanks uh Mr
President my name is
on economic policies the stability and
growth that new continuous experiences
especially in the sports pandemic
recovery period and especially if we're
focus on commitment of improving the
lives of those that are most in need of
the worst households in the country
um my question relates to a various
contrast perhaps between your foreign
policy and your domestic economic model
so domestically as we've explained today
you used to prioritize improving the
living conditions of those most in need
however in your foreign policy
you do recognize and support the regime
Venezuela
is this not to you and apparent
contradiction
to support a regime that has been
responsible for the largest amount of
human suffering in our contemporary
history in the region a country that now
76 percent of Venezuelans live in
extreme poverty under less than 1.90 a
day
so how can you play YouTube supports in
general improving the lives of the poor
while also supporting uh your gym
but well actually we don't support any
government except us
right
uh what we have do have is good
relations with everybody even with
United States
even when the United States we don't
uh you know we don't have bad relations
with you in European Union
European union and many countries you
know participate actively in the coup
d'etat in 2019
but we still have relations
and Bolivia is a country who always will
maintain good relations with all the
countries that is our foreign policy
we have a good relations with Chile for
example we have a huge problem there
about C
right
but Bolivia is always not supportive we
don't support any government
we have good relations with the
governments
so it's a difference we respect
the auto determination of the Nations if
they want to do what they do they want
to do in their country
it's their problem not our problem
we have to respect the way they decided
to live decided to do elections or not
elections or whatever regime political
regime they decided to adopt you know
the economic policy they decide to do we
live in a country where there are many
countries that are applying still they
are applying and the university are they
still teaching the neoliberalis model
and we respect it
I mean it's a way
it doesn't mean that we support them
you know I think we have to live in a
world where we have to respect each
other
that's the best way I would say to live
in peace and with everybody
thank you Mr President uh let me let me
ask a question going back to to your
your presentation and we can ask someone
else basically wants to ask a question
so I guess a something that was quite
surprising to me was a in the model that
uh that has been working let's say in
Bolivia this idea of 10 resources from
what used to be from the private sector
now belongs to the government the idea
of the resources however do we get these
resource basis on natural resources so
the question is but at the same time you
were fine you were showing a lot of
fermentary
data that actually firms had to be
actually going up over time so I guess a
one would actually as an economist
basically maybe would say in priori but
would expect something on the contrary
if it is the case of the government is
collecting rents from firms that will
descent device firm entry and firms
investing in the country so
how did this happen so can you so I'm
thinking about learning is it in
different sectors how come we are still
generating incentives for firms to
invest and enter in Bolivia when at the
same time you're telling us that some of
these resources actually are now
collected to go to the to the government
and the people okay
we differentiate
if there is a international Enterprise
that have to like to come to Bolivia to
work
and on the national resources like the
land for example or mining or American
bonds
the Constitution says that at least 51
percent has to belong to the estate
so we can make some business but in
national resources more than 51 percent
has to be for this state
you know that's one of the restrictions
in other sectors tourism Services
industry whatever
you don't have any limitation you you
can go ahead to have to 100 whatever no
problem at all
but for international resources we have
a restriction very clearly I in the
Constitution very very very interesting
anyone else has uh would like to yes
please
oh yes I mean I was doing it in English
but uh
yeah
my question I really appreciated you
mentioning Mother Earth I think it's
very important concept that is not
discussed in
and being Bolivia is such a rich country
in natural resources what has been the
main the main
challenge to respect mother
is
I as we're in Spanish
the third English and then we can we can
maybe assist in Spanish Spanish or
English or YouTube
I think some people will disagree in
English also but yeah okay okay
uh well
of course for every developing country
the worst problem that we're facing is
the cost of Technology
we would like for example to produce
clean energy
but it's Klinger that is very costly
that's why you always
in the the international forums we say
that developed countries
should sell us we don't want that they
give us that as a gift
but you know they they should sell us at
low very low prices the technology in
order to develop our countries
respecting Mother Earth
because it's very costly to to for
example a road
you should taking into account the cost
you should
build a straight Road
but in the middle you have you know a
natural reserve whatever
you have to go around it it's most
costly you know
and who may who give us the money for
that nobody nobody and everybody says in
the world everybody has to respect
Mother Earth everybody but it's costly
it's costly and it's much costal for us
to develop in this kind of circumstances
but I think this is the the main issue
the cost of the technology the cost of
developing that the developed countries
should take into account in order you
know to make policies in order to
respect to avoid some
crisis that could be in the you know in
the ecologic surroundings and so on
why don't I go yes
I don't know which one to do
Italian good morning Mr President
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
primero
economia
economy is
indigenous
territory
series
go organos or Co mechanismos de Mercado
de estado de cooperatives questions
foreign
super super so very interesting a
clearly very important question and yeah
and definitely the answer I I guess we
have time maybe for one more question
yeah that's okay or one more question
what's okay
so uh
yes sorry she she raised her hand before
so yes yeah
um
[Music]
natural resources and specifically
nowadays very important and as you may
know in Mexico corruption is a good
topic how to manage Community these
natural resources without falling into
like Interruption so um I would like to
listen to your change on how to have
like this economic surface within the
government but also guaranteeing and
profitable and transparent imagine
English
it's a good issue it's a good issue in
all the South American countries one of
the huge problems is corruption
especially in the public institutions
we can find a lot of cases and examples
that's why
we are very very
demanding with our public Enterprises
the difference is that the estate you
know the different institutions of the
estate and the public Enterprises we
have public Enterprises where those
Enterprises manage the national
resources
hydrocarbons Mining and so on so we have
create
a Ministry which is in charge of
corruption or fighting against
corruption you know
which is in charge of all these
institutions that have to report to this
a Ministry you know in order to to
clarify to transparency everything in
the process of
elicitations or sellings buyings and all
what the public Enterprises do in in
their activities so it is very important
this issue so far we didn't have huge
problems with the public Enterprise
because as everybody look at the public
Enterprises as the source of money for
growth for everybody a benefit
so everybody's looking at what's is
going on with the public Enterprises
in we have a law that two times a year
the public Enterprises all the public
Enterprises in Bolivia
have to go a public
report
for what they are doing
show the figures of the Enterprise you
know
they have to twice a year everybody
has access to all the information about
the public Enterprise that's the way we
are facing and also
in more practical issue
when a Enterprise or any public entity
wants to buy something you know
we are introducing an electronic uh
uh
auction auction
an electronic auction
so it has reduced a lot
the ministry of economy of Public
Finance report me two weeks ago that we
save money more more than 300 million
using this kind of electronic auctions
so it's more transparency is immediately
because everybody let's say the state
wants to buy paper
we put it in the web we want to buy 100
blocks of paper whatever
and everybody puts their offers there
and immediately you know who who wants
the this buying immediately very
transparent so we save a lot of money
and we did a more transparent process in
my country we had to introducing in
everybody in every buying and activities
of the public sector so we are improving
the transparency which is very useful
and you know is in line with your worry
I think that's the way we can face the
the problem transparency
Mr President thank you very much for
your talk for your time and I hope to
see you again at the Jackson School of
global Affairs so thank you very much to
the audience and the questions
[Applause]
[Music]